ich muss gar nicht dass sie auch Gemüse
parken darf hey Bruder sind irgendwo
Toiletten Bruder
klein die Brand hat Martin tobenen kein
die schade
oh mein Gott
immer diese peinlichen Influenza moin
bin übrigens in Amsterdam
[Musik]
mach mal so Standbild Video von mir wie
ich so schön Sitze einfach viele
Perspektiven
Film überhaupt
black ein privat Helikopter zum Hotel
gemietet
wenn das Bild ist schön aber irgendwie
unscharf
junge
[Musik]
eingeladen wurden und
ich weiß auch nicht sagen
wie so eine Klassenfahrt
dürfen wir schon sagen dass wir deswegen
genau
das ist noch in Holland dass sie da oben
einfach eine Zeit abspielen wann es rot
wird und wenn es grün ist dass sie eine
Zeit des Spielmanns wieder rot wird
Deutschland Scheibe abschneiden kann
hier vorne man muss so Sachen abgeben
darf was nicht weil es halt übel crazy
ist dass dieses Jahr eigentlich von der
Revolution stattfindet weil nach 30
Jahren echt krass was ändert das heißt
nicht mehr FIFA das heißt sondern jetzt
ist gut 24
[Applaus]
ich war komplett ab
das ist das Cover vom neuen fc24 das ist
halt auch dass die beim fc24 jetzt alle
Clubs Stadien Spieler Trikots alles
bleibt gleich also wir kriegen sogar
noch mehr Lizenz dazu
die Lizenz irgendwie verlieren oder
sowas
ich war noch nie auf so einem
Krankenhaus Event ich will ganz ehrlich
okay aber Ronaldo Alter das war mein
Idol als Kind ich stehe einfach
gespielt
aber ich glaube das ist der größte
Schritt in dieses Spiel jemals
ich würde jetzt hier essen wenn die
Durchfall verkaufen oder ich habe
ronaldinhode getroffen das war's vom
neuen easport FC 24 Event in Amsterdam
wo wir gerade waren wir gehen jetzt doch
tatsächlich in die City bisschen was
essen Amsterdam
moin ich bin auch schon eins sagen
das war's diese Stadt ist so schön
überall in jeder Gasse wartet so eine
kleine Überraschung auf einen wäre noch
schön wenn ich jetzt eine Pizza hätte
[Applaus]
gar nicht Geburtstag
rewi ist tatsächlich auch noch mit
gekommen was
wir sind jetzt hier im Rotlicht
angekommen also schon brutal es ist auf
dem Donnerstag hier gerade ne und es ist
unnormal voll und überall stehen halt so
Mädels in den Schaufenster und verkaufen
Dienste als wären die halt irgendwelche
Produkte an das ist irre auf dem
Donnerstag die Stadt ist cool cool der
ist auch cool
[Musik]
dass ich ein Hund eine Ratte und ein
Schrank
ja dann kann ich aus dem Urlaub zurück
und habe dann vorher die Videokameras
gecheckt und habe gesehen dass Leute
meiner Wohnung waren und haben die Essen
für mich gekocht und dann kam ich nach
Hause und habe das halt gegessen und so
habe dann weiter die Videokameras
geschickt dann habe ich auf dem
Videokameras gesehen dass sie meinen
Hund und meinen Schrank in der Pfanne
gepackt kann angebraten mit das
hingestellt haben als hätte mein eigenen
Hund mein eigenen Schrank gegessen
an der Stelle guten Morgen wir sind
jetzt gerade beim Hotels Frühstück
ich weiß nicht ob ich der einzige bin
aber ich fühle mich bei so Hotel
Frühstück ist immer so als würde ich
irgendwas falsch machen von allen Seiten
kommen irgendwelche Leute
trymacs hier von allen Seiten kommen
immer irgendwelche Rennen Senioren an
und ich habe immer das Gefühl ich stehe
falsch ich hole die falschen Sachen ich
stehe im Weg
ich habe keine Ahnung
was geht ab ich bin's Laser Luca und wir
gehen jetzt in einen Süßigkeitenladen
hier in Amsterdam
das ist einfach der größte
Süßigkeitenladen den ich je gesehen habe
und das ist nur die untere Etage die
haben noch zwei weitere Etagen wir haben
jetzt einen anderen Süßigkeitenladen
gefunden namens Jamin die jetzt auch
irgendwie voll viele haben und wir
wollten einfach so ein paar holländische
Süßigkeiten oder niederländische
Süßigkeiten mal testen und wir sehen uns
gleich wieder wenn wir die gekauft haben
Freunde wow Leute was geht ab wir sind
jetzt auf dem Rückweg zurück nach
Deutschland und wir sehen uns wieder
wenn wir in Deutschland sind Leute was
geht ab wir sind wieder in Deutschland
angekommen und wir testen sie
Süßigkeiten gekauft haben Leute was geht
ab wir sind an meinem Küchentisch oh
wir haben in den Niederlanden Pringles
mit Pizza Geschmack gekauft dann noch
einen Lolli mit Marihuana Geschmack
Gummibärchen mit Schokolade überzogen
einen brain Blaster keine Ahnung was das
ist Tetris Gummibärchen Cotton Candy
Süßigkeiten und Fantag
und mit dieser Weintrauben gemacht
Shisha
aber schmeckt scheiße
will ich nicht kaufen
ehrlich
[Gelächter]
wir haben nur noch zwei Produkte übrig
und zwar den Marihuana Lutscher und die
fluffy stuff Rainbow shared golden Candy
was ist Rainbow für ein Geschmack das
werde ich nicht verstehen
was soll ein Hund für ein Geschmack sein
und zu guter Letzt kommen wir jetzt auch
noch zum Marihuana Lutscher der soll
einen anscheinend nicht high machen
sondern nur den Geschmack vermitteln wie
Marihuana schmeckt
das ist einfach Erde
er riecht scheiße und der schmeckt
scheiße
damit allerdings auch beenden meine
Damen und Herren danke schön 24 dass sie
dieses Video hier und den Trip nach
Amsterdam überhaupt erst möglich gemacht
haben es war auf jeden Fall sehr sehr
cool die Süßigkeiten Challenge hat auf
jeden Fall ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen
bereitet allerdings trotzdem gefallen
hat dann lasst einen Daumen hoch und
dann wieder da abonniert meinen Kanal
und klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nichts verpassen
schönen Tag